With fewer content restrictions than an MCU
film and more room to flesh out its characters,
one of the best parts of Marvel's Netflix series
was its villains. From ninjas to mercenaries,
from maniacs to crime lords, here are the MCU's
Netflix villains ranked from worst to best.
The Hand is a criminal organization whose
shuriken-tossing soldiers have been leaping
through Marvel's comics for a long time,
and they make their presence felt in half of
Marvel's Netflix offerings. While making them
an integral part of Charlie Cox’s Daredevil's
story is accurate to the source material, you
could argue that in the MCU Netflix series,
they were a big part of the
series' drop in quality.
The Netflix heroes were best when dealing
with challenges grounded in the real world.
Daredevil's greatest villain is a crime lord.
Krysten Ritter's Jessica Jones wrestles with the
trauma she endured from a sexual predator. And Jon
Bernthal's Frank Castle goes up against corrupt
soldiers for hire in The Punisher's first season.
These are all exaggerated versions of people who,
sadly, exist in the real world. Making a
centuries-old clandestine organization filled
with ninjas and superpowered warriors brought the
narrative to a place that felt more like fantasy.
“Yeah, a little bit.”
When it comes to bad guys, you can't go wrong
with Clancy Brown. The man who famously played the
merciless Kurgen in 1986's Highlander shows up in
season 2 of Daredevil as Colonel Ray Schoonover.
He is one of the men responsible for
the death of Frank Castle's family.
As one of the leaders of the Cerberus
Squad, Schoonover secretly funneled
heroin from Afghanistan to the United
States in order to line his pockets.
The colonel's low placement on the list
is only because we hardly get to know him.
Schoonover shows up for only two episodes
of Daredevil, and in his second appearance,
he becomes one of Frank Castle's victims. Brown
briefly reprises the role for flashbacks in the
first season of The Punisher. He's great at
conveying the feel of a once proud officer,
who's now a slave to his need for
power and wealth. But unfortunately,
we only get so much time with him before
Castle gives him what he deserves.
Willis Stryker, aka Diamondback, is played by Erik
LaRay Harvey, and he starts off strong. He first
appears halfway through Luke Cage's inaugural
season, and he quickly becomes the biggest threat
to the titular hero. It's Stryker who brings the
Hammer Industries tech into Harlem to fight Luke
Cage. This includes the Judas Bullets — the only
ammo capable of piercing Cage's skin — and the
suit of body armor he wears to fight Cage in the
season 1 finale. Of all antagonists in that first
season, he's the only one who presents
any kind of physical challenge to Cage.
But in part, it's the physical threat to Cage
that ruins Diamondback. His Iron Man-light suit
is just about the goofiest looking thing in
the entire Luke Cage series. It contrasts
sharply against a show otherwise set in
a world that doesn't feel too far removed
from the real one. Their big brawl at the
end of the first season, while engaging,
can take you out of the story faster than
just about anything else in the series.
Sowande, played by Babs Olusanmokun, is
one of the founders of the Hand. And as
one of the so-called Five Fingers of the Hand,
Sowande has had his life extended for centuries,
and he hasn't been idle in that time. Sowande is
a master of martial arts. Without any superhuman
strength backing him up, he's able to make short
work of Luke Cage through the manipulation of
pressure points in The Defenders, and
he's likewise undefeated by Iron Fist.
But despite his martial arts prowess,
Sowande is one of the more forgettable
villains of MCU's Netflix series. He lives and
dies within the only season of The Defenders,
beheaded by Daredevil's mentor
Stick, played by Scott Glenn,
and denied the immortal life that he and the
other leaders of the Hand crave. If most of
The Defenders is best left forgotten — and it is
— then Sowande has a head start. Pun intended.
Elodie Yung's portrayal of Elektra
Natchios in season 2 of Daredevil
is one of the bright spots in the
weakest of the show's three seasons.
Yung perfectly embodies the deadly warrior
who's both in love with Matthew Murdock
and wants him to adopt less merciful tactics in
his role as Daredevil. With her multiple deaths
and resurrections in the source material, a tragic
death and a dark return were all but guaranteed.
Even so, it's after her resurrection in The
Defenders that this warrior loses her spark.
When she's brought back to life in The Defenders,
Elektra may still be good at fighting and killing,
but she simply isn't as compelling a character.
As Alexandra Reid's right-hand woman, Elektra is
practically mindless, not truly emerging from her
post-resurrection haze until she kills Reid. It's
possible we could have seen a more interesting
version of Elektra as a villain if Daredevil had
continued, but unfortunately, her final appearance
is in the series finale of The Defenders.
The Bride of Nine Spiders, played by Jane Kim,
proves a worthy opponent for Danny Rand in season
1 of Iron Fist. The seductive and skilled martial
artist comes close to defeating the hero, but
compared to the other villains on this list, the
Bride has a couple of things working against her.
First, we never see the Bride again
after "Immortal Emerges from Cave,"
giving her a distinct "villain of the week"
feel. Second, while we normally wouldn't
automatically fault a series from diverting from
the source material, the Bride is a special case.
In the comics, we first meet the Bride in
2007's Immortal Iron Fist #8 as part of a
tournament with the champions of all the immortal
cities. When it's her turn to fight in the arena,
the Bride displays the impressive and
terrifying ability to summon seemingly
endless swarms of spiders at her opponents.
Adapting the character without that ability,
especially considering the incredible
visuals it could've led to, feels criminal.
Theo Rossi has a knack for getting memorable roles
with unique nicknames. On Sons of Anarchy, Rossi
played the biker Juice, while on Luke Cage, he
played one of the series' more interesting crooks
— Shades. In the first season, Shades is fairly
low in the Stokes crime family pecking order,
but even then, there's a lot going on behind
the lenses of his namesake. While people like
Cottonmouth, played by Mahershala Ali and Mariah
Dillard, played by Alfre Woodard, may be the ones
sitting on Harlem's throne at any given time, it's
Shades manipulating things behind the curtain.
In the second season, Shades moves up the
ladder, owing in no small part to his romance
with Dillard. His cool facade finally cracks
when Dillard forces him to kill his true love,
Comanche, played by Thomas Q. Jones. It
puts him on the path of betraying Dillard,
but he remains the same charismatic,
cool bad guy to the end of the series.
Few characters seem to bounce back and forth
between friend and enemy as much as Will Simpson,
played by Wil Traval, does in the
first season of Jessica Jones. His
complex journey is as compelling as it
is tumultuous. Introduced as a policeman
manipulated to attack Trish Walker by
the mind-bending abilities of Kilgrave,
Simpson tries to make things up to his victim
once he's free of Kilgrave's influence.
Simpson eventually wins Walker's trust, but
his road to redemption takes dark turns. We
learn that in the military, Simpson was a part
of some scary experiments, including being given
drugs to enhance his abilities, and he begins
taking those drugs once more. While they may
help him physically, the drugs wreck his sanity,
putting him on a collision course with Jessica.
Will reappears in season 2, but he doesn't last
long. Once again trying to make up for his crimes,
Simpson tries to protect Trish, but
he's killed by Jessica's mother.
In some ways, you could say Davos, played by
Sacha Dhawan, is to Danny Rand what the MCU's
Loki is to Thor. Just as Loki is jealous of
the love and admiration all of Asgard feels
for the god of thunder, Davos envies Danny for
winning the mantle of Iron Fist. Even more,
Davos hates Danny for what he sees as squandering
that power. He's Danny's primary antagonist
in season 2 of Iron Fist, going to increasingly
darker lengths to claim Rand's power for his own.
Since Davos is introduced in the first season,
we get to watch his descent from
Danny Rand's ally to his nemesis.
“I’m not going to give up hope that,
one day, you’ll come back to yourself.”
Dhawan is believable as the villain known in the
comics as the Steel Serpent, and his conflict with
Rand is one of the things that makes Iron Fist's
second season a vast improvement from the first.
While the Hand pops up in both Daredevil and
Iron Fist, it's finally in The Defenders that we
meet its leader, Alexandra Reid. Sigourney Weaver
doesn't play villains often enough, and her time
as Alexandra Reid is proof. Weaver is perfectly
chosen as the Hand's otherwise immortal leader,
who finally feels the approach of death.
As Reid, she exudes power, ruthlessness,
and nothing more than perhaps some dismissive
pity for the band of heroes trying to stop her.
Sadly, while Weaver is one of the best reasons
to watch The Defenders, that list isn't very
long. Among other flaws, the series was too
short and packed with too many characters.
Before we hardly get a chance to
enjoy Weaver in this villainous role,
Elektra kills her. It's a shame that when
it was Weaver's time to join the MCU,
it was in a role that didn't have
the time to stretch its legs.
Sure, the first season of Iron Fist is
probably one of the weakest seasons of
all of Marvel's Netflix series, but as a
bad guy, Harold Meachum is pretty great.
The manipulative, solitary killer spends
much of the series in his penthouse,
plotting and abusing his grown children.
Then there's the brokenness he brought
to Danny’s family, as he was the one who
arranged for the deaths of Danny's parents.
David Wenham is great as Meachum, who delves
deeper into insanity as the season continues,
caught between Iron Fist and the
Hand. Wenham is likely best known as
Boromir's more resilient brother,
Faramir, in the Lord of the Rings films.
So, it's refreshingly unsettling to
see him in a role that pushes so hard
in the other direction. It's too bad the season
as a whole wasn't as good as Wenham's performance.
Alisa Jones, played by Janet McTeer, never
really had much of a chance. In Jessica
Jones' second season, we learn she survived
the car crash that killed her son and husband,
after which she was nursed back to health
and given powers by the scientist Karl Malus.
By the time Alisa and Jessica are reunited,
Alisa's dedication to Malus reaches a manic pitch,
making her dangerous to anyone near
her, especially after Malus dies.
After the much more cerebral and emotional
threat of Kilgrave in Jessica Jones' first
season, someone who could pose more of
a physical challenge to the hero was the
obvious choice. And McTeer
is wonderful in the role.
She brings a fierceness to Alisa that
makes you believe she's capable of
anything — including hurting, or even killing,
the daughter she's just been reunited with.
The assassin John Pilgrim, played by Josh Stewart,
is singular in the ranks of Punisher villains.
This is for no other reason than the fact that
the guy actually survives his clash with
Frank Castle. With his priest's collar and
the unsettling calm with which he doles
out violence, Pilgrim is one of the most
chilling and disturbing villains to show up in
The Punisher or any of Marvel's Netflix shows.
We eventually learn that as
skilled as he is at killing,
Pilgrim is far from being a conscienceless
killer. A former member of the Aryan Brotherhood,
Pilgrim eventually saw the evil of
his ways, converted to Christianity,
and became a pastor. His bloody rampage
through the second season of The Punisher
is the result of the manipulative Schultzes
keeping his children hostage. It's Pilgrim's
dedication to his family that convinces Frank
to spare his life in spite of his crimes.
Trish Walker is perhaps the most tragic character
in any of Marvel's Netflix series. When we meet
her in the first season of Jessica Jones,
she's the titular hero's best friend and
the survivor of a horrible assault. As the
series continues, her desire to be more like
Jessica leads her to increasingly dangerous
extremes. Unfortunately, this includes her
taking the same addicting medications that gave
the late Will Simpson his enhanced abilities.
Surprised to find herself with powers, Walker goes
down roads she can't turn back from in the show's
final season. She becomes a self-styled vigilante,
but her time as a crime-fighter leaves a lot to be
desired. Among other things, she accidentally
causes one attacker to fall on her own weapon
and flees the scene rather than helping. She kills
Gregory Sallinger just before the series finale,
and the final battle of Jessica Jones
proves to be between Jones and Walker.
William Rawlins, played by Paul Schulze, is
precisely the kind of guy Frank Castle was
born to kill. When Castle first meets
Rawlins in Afghanistan, the CIA agent
seems like someone Castle is
destined to lock horns with.
This is even before Castle learns that Rawlins
and Schoonover are using their squad to smuggle
heroin back to the United States. It's also
Rawlins who orders the hit on Castle's life,
leading to deaths of his wife and their two
children. So, inevitably, it is Rawlins who
meets his own brutal end at Castle's hands
before The Punisher's first season is over.
With his freezing glare and permanent
scowl, Paul Schulze is utterly believable
as the corrupt operative who left his
conscience far behind long ago. He's the
perfect villain for The Punisher's inaugural
season, and his air of cold arrogance clashes
wonderfully with the more likable villainy
of Frank Castle's old friend, Billy Russo.
What do you say about a man who almost kills a
chef because he doesn't like how he cooks steak?
Well, you call him whatever you want,
just make sure it's out of his earshot.
In the final season of Jessica Jones,
Jeremy Bobb plays Gregory Sallinger,
a serial killer who targets anyone he views
as being morally bankrupt or unworthy of
their place in society. Could be bad chefs,
blackmailers, or superpowered private detectives.
Sallinger is highly intelligent and has spent
his life honing the different skills he would
need to be a prolific serial killer. But as
challenging an enemy as he is to Jessica Jones,
his crushing self-loathing and self-doubt shine
through more than anything else. It's clear
that no matter how much he accomplishes
or what he proves himself capable of,
the voices inside Sallinger will
never allow it to be enough.
“And that is extraordinary.”
In the third season of Daredevil, Benjamin
Poindexter, played by Wilson Bethel,
is a FBI agent who Wilson Fisk manipulates
into becoming his worst self. Bethel plays
a man who's learned to manage his mental illness.
Fisk learns Poindexter's coping skills and works
to tear them all down so that all Poindexter is
left with is madness. As a killer, Poindexter
is arguably the greatest physical challenge
Murdock faces in the course of his series.
Pointdexter’s backstory was an addition not
found in his comic character, where he goes
by “Bullseye.” He is never directly referred
to as "Bullseye" in the show. However, the end
of season 3 strongly hinted that we were going
to see the return of the former FBI agent. Were
the series to have continued, maybe he would’ve
come back as “Bullseye.” Guess we’ll never know.
Few villains change as drastically between
seasons as The Punisher's Billy Russo,
played by Ben Barnes. In the beginning
of the first season of The Punisher,
Russo acts like Frank Castle's friend, but
we soon learn he was in bed with Rawlins and
Schoonover in the Cerberus Squad. Of all of
Castle's enemies from his special ops days,
Russo is the only one to survive
the first season, but he doesn't
do it unscathed. Castle leaves Russo with
the scars that earn him the name Jigsaw.
Traumatized by his confrontation
with Castle, Russo temporarily loses
all memory of the last few years in The Punisher's
second season. Here, actor Ben Barnes shows us a
more vulnerable side of Jigsaw, who spends months
recovering mentally and physically. Ultimately,
Billy Russo acts true to form, seducing
his therapist and building a new gang
of crooks and killers. But Castle gives
Russo the death he deserves in the end.
In his final moments, Russo apologizes to his
old friend, but Castle hardly seems to care.
It isn't tough to imagine how
Cornell Stokes, aka Cottonmouth,
won the loyalty of the crooks under his
command. Along with the more obvious
threats and incentives someone like Stokes
would use to build a criminal organization,
of all the villains we meet in Luke Cage,
he has the most magnetic personality.
Mahershala Ali's brilliant performance
is mesmerizing enough that you actually
believe the confidence of that big laugh of
his. It doesn’t matter that one confrontation
after another shows he has no good ideas about
how to handle Luke Cage. His death at Mariah
Dillard's hands in the middle of the first
season is that much more shocking because
of Ali's work. Even as Mariah furiously
finishes him off with a mic stand,
it's tough to believe the series is getting rid of
one of its most entertaining characters so soon.
Bushmaster, played by Mustafa Shakir, is the first
villain in Luke Cage to give the titular hero
any kind of physical challenge without
the help of Judas Bullets or power suits.
In the opening moments of season 2's "I
Get Physical," Bushmaster leaves Luke Cage
unconscious on the Harlem sidewalk using
only his martial arts skills, his speed,
and his enhanced strength. The Brooklyn
native uses the Jamaican herb Nightshade
to boost his strength and durability, rendering
his skin almost as impervious as Cage's.
Bushmaster is a clever, charismatic bad guy, and
it's tough to not sympathize with him. He's in
Harlem looking for vengeance on the Stokeses. His
own family was killed by the late Stokes matriarch
Mama Mabel and her gang. Cage and Bushmaster
eventually forge an uneasy alliance to stop Mariah
Dillard, but it ends when Bushmaster proves more
willing to resort to murder than Cage would like.
Two episodes before Wilson Fisk appears in
Daredevil's first season, we're introduced
to his most trusted adviser — James Wesley,
played by Toby Leonard Moore. Well-dressed,
soft-spoken, and eloquent, Wesley is likely one of
the last men you'd guess is a high-ranking member
in a violent criminal organization. Yet in his
first scene, Wesley calmly sits on a park bench
next to a man who owes Fisk money and delivers
a monstrous threat against the man's daughter.
"Now, you see this man here? If we're
being honest with each other, Mr. Farnum,
I find his methods unpleasant."
It's because Wesley isn't the guy who works
with guns or knives that he's such a great
villain. He delivers his blows with a word or
a look. Wesley represents the more civilized
side of Wilson Fisk, the part of himself
that the crime lord wants the world to see.
That's a big part of the reason
why when Karen Page kills Wesley,
Fisk begins to do away with his photogenic facade
and deal with his enemies much more brazenly.
While it wasn't enough to save the
series, Iron Fist's second season is a
vast improvement on the first. One
of the things that makes season 2 so
much better is Alice Eve's portrayal
of the mentally fractured Mary Walker.
Every scene she's in makes you
worry about what she might do.
Employed by Joy Meachum first to follow
Danny Rand and then to get more hands on,
Walker is one of the most intimidating and
challenging foes Rand faces in the series.
In spite of having no enhanced abilities, through
skill and careful planning, Mary wipes the floor
with Danny Rand in their first fight on
a subway platform in "Target: Iron Fist."
Madame Gao, played by Wai Ching Ho,
is one of the most dangerous people
you'll meet in Marvel's Netflix shows. She
presents herself as a physically frail,
elderly woman in order to give enemies and
allies alike a false sense of security.
She prefers to work from the shadows, letting her
actions speak for her and foregoing the noise and
bravado of other bad guys. While she tends to be
a puppet master more than anything else, we learn
in The Defenders that Gao has physical abilities
that allow her to go toe to toe with Iron Fist.
Not only is Madame Gao one of the
strongest pieces of connective
tissue throughout Marvel's Netflix series,
she's perhaps the absolute last person you
want to mess with. She may not lash
out in aggressive and bloody ways,
but she'll give you that wicked smile
and just wait until the time is right.
In the first half of Luke Cage's first
season, Mariah Dillard wants Harlem to
see her as the legitimate face of the Stokes
family. So, she allows Cornell to lord over
the criminal elements of the neighborhood.
Things change when he implies the sexual
abuse Dillard endured at the hands of her uncle
was consensual. She kills Cornell in his club,
and, supported by the manipulative Shades,
soon becomes the queen of crime in Harlem.
Alfre Woodard may have already had a
role in the MCU — as a grieving mother
in 2016's Captain America: Civil War.
However, her performance in Luke Cage
overrides any concerns a continuity
stickler might have. Through Woodard,
Mariah is a tortured villain, haunted by the
abuse she suffered from her criminal family.
Her rage and pain is bubbling at the surface
of every scene, and she's merciless enough
to leave no mystery as to how she could ever
be a threat to a man with bulletproof skin.
Few of Marvel's Netflix villains could leave such
a lasting impression as Jessica Jones' Kilgrave,
played by David Tennant. Gifted with the
ability to make anyone do what he tells them,
Kilgrave makes every character a potential
time bomb. Before the events of the series,
he uses his powers to force Jessica Jones
do a lot of things she doesn't want to do,
including commit murder. The trauma she
suffers at his hands is what makes the hero
so miserable, and his presence is felt
throughout the show's amazing first season,
even long before he and Jessica
finally reunite face to face.
David Tennant's performance is such that — even
though Jones kills him in the season 1 finale — he
never fully leaves the series. Kilgrave leaves
scars in Jessica too deep to let him die for good.
We see this most clearly in season 2's "AKA
Three Lives and Counting," when Jones is
plagued by visions of Kilgrave harassing her
and tempting her to lash out with violence.
It's unthinkable to imagine someone other than
Vincent D'Onofrio in the role of Daredevil's most
important villain, Wilson Fisk. For the show's
three seasons, which is more than most of the
Marvel Netflix series got and yet hardly feels
like enough, D'Onofrio's time as Fisk was one of
the best reasons to watch Daredevil. D'Onofrio
provides the perfect mix of intelligence,
civility, ruthlessness, rage, and turbulent
pain to bring us the man the comic books
call the Kingpin. It's probably
not a coincidence that season 2 is
generally regarded as the weakest chapter
of Daredevil, since Fisk is mostly absent.
He only appears in the final moments of the
season's eighth episode, "Guilty as Sin."
Wilson Fisk embodies the incredible potential
of the stories that were being told on Netflix's
Marvel shows. Fisk is no alien warlord or an
Asgardian god jealous of his brother. He's a
man of wealth, whose childhood scars drive
him to evil, and nothing about that sounds
like make-believe. There's no reason why someone
like Wilson Fisk couldn't exist in the real world,
and that makes him more terrifying than
any other MCU villain you can think of.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes and villains are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.